Hey, pretty time.
Hi, Jose, how are you?
I'm doing good. How are you doing?
Not too bad. I'm good. Just struggling with my heart.
Not so bad means, not so bad means there's a certain degree of bad.
Yeah, and the weather here, it's rainy, and you know...
Am I right or am I right?
It's raining.
The monsoon is here, so kind of cold.
slightly like body ache, feverish, getting lazy to get out of bed. You know this kind, you know? Don't feel like coming to work.
*** ****.
Ha ha ha!
Sounds like you work for Ivy.
Oh.
So, like a T1 for Ivy.
No, it's just the weather here.
That now I understand, it's the weather.
Yeah.
It happens, it will stay for like another two, three months here, like unpredictable rains with strong winds.
Need.
So, after that, it's again a nice little island for vacation.
No, that.
Those islands were not meant to be inhabited, by the way. They were just for show.
And trust me, the skyscrapers we have here, they're like 61, 70 floors high. And when these winds blow, it's so hard to stand in the balcony.
Okay.
No, I would faint. I would not.
Yeah.
I would not be out there for one second. Not for one second. I went to...
In April, I was in Singapore and Malaysia. I went to Singapore 1st and then I went to Malaysia. And similar experiences, the humidity almost killed me. And I'm from Florida, so that says a lot. The humidity here sometimes can be 100% without rain. Go figure. But it's really, really, really, really humid in Florida. But when I went over there to that side of
Uh-huh.
Yep.
Stop.
You know, to that hemisphere, it was the weather over there is very brutal.
Mm.
Yep, it's quite humid here. Even though it's raining and like it's almost raining for seven, 8 hours now continuously, but still if you go out for a little walk, you start perspering. It's so humid.
Yeah.
Alright, that's...
How do you know it's sweat? How do you know it's not just the humidity and the rain?
Yeah.
Yes.
I often wonder, but I don't care; it feels like sweat, like I, I, the five seconds it takes to get from the car inside to the building, torture, torture.
Kurt.
Yes.
I know, I know, dude.
Yeah.
All right, is that it from your side, Pritam? Nobody else is joining today?
All right.
I believe so. Natalie is out of office. She is out for some conference. Lee, most probably, he's not in a different call, I think. Yeah. Okay, so to start with, yes, William, Jose.
Anything for me?
I'll let Will go first.
Nothing major at the moment. I feel like we're getting a better grasp on things as we move along here. Something I do want us to continue working on, and I'll definitely make it a point to continue stress with the team as well, is just
It kind of got mentioned last week as well, just not last week, I'm sorry, last meeting, just trying to drive a...
Uh, uh.
How do I want to phrase it? AA.
I don't want to say more urgent, but just a, trying to make sure that people feel, you know, as they're working tickets throughout the day, just trying to make sure they're checking their inbox to check for the status of tickets, check on, you know, specifically things assigned to themselves. You know, I definitely review tickets throughout the day. The team lead reviews tickets throughout the day, but
We want, you know, it's easier for an engineer to keep an eye on, you know, the 10 or 15 tickets they have assigned to them versus, you know, us trying to keep track of, you know, the 100 or 200 that are in the queue at any given time, you know, hoping that we notice it. So, as an example, I found this morning.
I was looking over tickets and I saw one that an engineer picked up Friday and it hadn't been actioned yet. And I should have seen it yesterday, but it was Monday, Mondays are Monday. So, you know, I too, you know, full disclosure, I have a role to play in that getting missed, but you know, that's one of those things that's like, man, if they would have just called it out to me on Friday, I could have just.
No.
done it Friday myself. But you like it was what it was just an escalation ticket. It would have taken no more than five, 7 minutes to do. But you know, throughout the course of a busy day, it's those little things like that, just trying to make sure, you know, if you know, being mindful of what you have. And also not even just because of the simple fact of like, you know, they obviously they take multiple things at a time, but
Mhm.
You know, if your team leader or somebody assigned you something, maybe you're on a call at the time, you know, it's easy for that to for you to forget. Again, I'm guilty of grabbing tickets and then being like, oh crap, I didn't get back to that ticket yet. So that's why it's just little things of trying to force them to get into the habit of.
You know, when I was a tier 1 engineer, I tried to pretty much in between every ticket, just take a glance at my queue just to see, did anything change of importance? So I can keep an eye out for those sorts of things. So just trying to continue to drive a stronger sense of ownership around their personal inbox for which contains all the tickets that are assigned to them.
Yep.
But yeah, I feel like as far as dealing with incoming items, we're still continuing to succeed. You know, Ivy has been, they've been giving us compliments on the metrics in terms of the SLAs, because we have a weekly meeting, review that with them every Tuesday. So they like what they're seeing in that regard, but
You know, the metrics we want to try to drive down now are things that aren't things that we don't, you know, they're not SLAs on Ivy's side, which are gonna be, well, that's not true. Some of them are, but things like just general like time to resolution, but you know, Ivy doesn't have a, they don't have an SLA for time to resolution for something like request tickets, but.
Ohh.
It's something that data prize obviously naturally still, of course, tracks, so we want to make sure that we're not leaving tickets lingering for too long. And I feel like the easiest way to make sure we attack that is just making sure we, trying to make sure we get back to things that we started to work on and had to put down for whatever the reason may be. There's plenty of reasons why it could happen for Ivy. And those users are.
Mhm.
They're doctors and clinicians and stuff, so they're in and out all the time. So you're not always going to have access for very long. So you might have to stop working on something and come back to it. And that's fine. We just got to make sure we come back to it is the key there.
No, understood here. So William, when you say inbox, you're talking about the thread inbox, right? Checking the thread inbox. Yep.
Yeah.
Yes.
Yeah, case in point, like I can, I'll share my screen real fast so you can see, because I actually have my inbox up and that's one of the things I was doing like right before this meeting. So every morning when I come in, like now this is my inbox, these are all the tickets assigned to me personally. And I do grab tickets for time and time just to, again, I try to do my part to make things easy on the team. So anything that I know I can get done quick or I already have the answers for it, I'll just grab it.
So case in point, like this is one that I literally grabbed about an hour or so ago, and I was, my plan was to go ahead and get this knocked out. Hadn't gotten back to it yet. So, and this is exactly what I'm talking about. This is an escalation ticket. This is just gonna be, this particular ticket is just an escalation to our PC depot department. I just have to update some ticket fields for them and get it moved on over to their queue, and then they'll take care of it. But you know, it's one of those tickets that's in a weird place because.
You know, PC Depot tickets, they're just escalations. They're not high priority tickets for us, but it could be very easily be a high priority depending on the date that the person is saying they need this by. So that's why we want to make sure we get it into PC Depot's hands as soon as possible, because either, you know, the IV is, they don't always do a great job of giving us a...
Mhm.
Advance notice on some of the things that they need. So that's we I just want to make sure that the service desk isn't the reason that something gets held up.
No, makes sense, makes sense, definitely. I will have this conversation with the team too, just to keep an eye on your inbox as well.
So.
Yeah, yeah, every engineer has, they have their inbox and every ticket that in your name is in here. So I just make it a point every day when I come in, I just scroll down. Of course, it's different for me as a manager when I come in because the night team will assign me tickets so that I can reassign them that day. But to the same degree as an engineer, same purpose. You can easily quickly see exactly everything you have. And obviously you can see.
Yep.
It has a status listed there, so you can quickly see, you know, like I got this one I know I gotta do tomorrow when I come in. So I got a scheduled ticket I have to take care of. These I already took care of today, just waiting to see if the person responds back to what I said. And once I complete this one, I don't have any other tickets assigned to me for right now. So same thing for the engineers, just trying to make sure that.
throughout their day, trying to work in times to just look at your inbox, make sure that you've responded to everything in it.
And if they can't respond to everything in it, we want them to call that out to us and say, like, hey, I have, you know, 20, 30 tickets, you know, they're backing up, you know, what can I, you know, can I get some time out of the queue to address what I have? Or, you know, maybe we can't give you that time out of the queue, but even you just saying that lets us know, like, okay, let me review what they have to see what I can do.
Yup.
Definitely, definitely, William. I will talk with the team regarding it, and yes, they should take ownership of their own inbox rather than like chats, emails, tickets, and the calls.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Right, what else?
That's the main thing for me.
I think, I think, as far as I'm concerned at the moment, our main challenge is just trying to, like, we're doing a good job on, like I said, on incoming items, things within SLA there.
Ohh.
If we can just do a do a better job of staying on top of, you know, following up on things that we couldn't get resolved the first time, you know, Ivy's, you know, with their, they have a really good, was it FCR? Why can't it first first contact resolution? I was blanking on it, but yeah, their first contact resolution is looking great.
So if it's something that we can get taken care of the first time, we are. So we have a good percentage of that. So the only thing now is just dealing with the items that are lingering. And some of that, quite honestly, it's not entirely the team's fault because we have things that are, we're working with other vendors and things like that. So if they're not doing their part, then these things drag.
But for our part, we have to make sure that we're staying on top of them to make sure that if they're dragging, we kind of want to call it out. We just want to say, like, hey, what's happening with this? You know, hey, any, you know, what's the latest update on this? And then if we have to take it to Ivy's leadership to say, like, hey, you know, this vendor's really dragging their feet on this stuff and our tickets are sitting around, we just want to be able to tell that story.
That's all.
No, understood. Definitely. Okay. Anything apart from this? Okay. Now I can see this team is doing good now, IV team. I can see more confidence when I talk to them. I can see that smile in their face now. Before it was like, okay, they are getting overwhelmed, but now I can see that smile when they work.
Not for me.
which means a lot to me. So Jose was pretty much right. Getting used to the environment is giving them more confidence and way around the navigation and stuff like that. Cool.
No, it's normal. It's human nature, right? I'm not gonna, I don't have much to say. Lucky for you too today.
But, how they?
Yep.
Ouch, you just went ready.
No, you guys have already touched on every point that I was going to mention. The team is 100% demonstrating a new level of confidence. They're getting more comfortable. The issue remains. Resolution times are way too long, but we are seeing improvement.
Yeah.
Ha ha ha!
The.
Mhm.
incidents, for example, you know, week over week, they're at a 36% improvement in the time that tickets are sitting, but we're still in the red in those areas. Everywhere else, they're trending, everywhere they're trending in the right direction.
And then the areas that they're not where like abandon rate, you know, is slightly higher, but volume is also a little bit higher. So that's, you know, it's understandable. But still we've been target and looking good. All the numbers that are in the red are trending green. So we're looking good.
Good, good to know that.
The biggest issue is...
getting the tickets resolved, right? We get to them in a good time, but then they just sit there for a long time. So that's the time that we need to work on right now. And like Will mentioned, when they do touch the tickets, they're either, I don't know, password resets. I can't understand the FCR. It's ridiculous. 92% last week, 91%.
Mhm.
Resolution time.
92% the week prior, 91% the two week previous to last week, and 91% for last week, which is very, very good. So yeah, I can't say much, right? It looks like we're moving in the right direction, so I am very happy.
Attendance still continues to be a big thing for me. Had another call out today. Not going to mention anymore. Today's was his first call out, by the way, so I mean he puts out outstanding numbers, so I'm good. But I'm not letting up on the attendance like you need.
Yep, 72,000.
Yes.
They need to understand that, like, it doesn't work if they're not here.
Mhm.
But yeah, that's all I have for you guys today. It's an easy day. We're seeing the improvements, communication network, or the feedback that we're giving you and the team is being acted on, and that's all we really could expect. And I'm happy. I'm good. As long as we continue to move in this direction.
Right.
Thank you, thank you so much, Jose. This really matters A lot. So, a few things from my end. Sorry, Namit, I will come back to you later. Like, just want to end up this conversation here. So, not thoroughly. Yeah.
Pritam.
So sorry, before you move on to your items, are your items at all related to what Jose just said? Because I just wanted to check about one thing that he just said.
Regarding what?
I wanted to check with something Jose just said. So if your items are moving along, can I just really quickly check in? Okay. All right. Great. Yeah, I didn't mean to interrupt the flow. I just want to make sure that we're being thorough here. So, Jose, and forgive if I missed it, right, either in other context or on these calls.
Yeah, definitely, definitely. You can go ahead.
Do we know where the delta is between getting fast response times, but long delayed closures? Is it escalation's not happening when it needs to? Is it they're not being efficient in their usage of time?
What, what do we both of those things?
No, #2. Number 2. Yeah, no, so you're right. Will did go over that in the beginning. And I was looking at some other numbers. Lee, I don't even know if you have joined yet, but.
Number 2, ohh, so.
Okay.
Yeah, I, I jumped out of trying to check up and catch up on a couple of other things here related to you guys. I, so we'll forget. I, I...
No, no, it's okay. Yes, 100%. It's their ability of organizing how they're going to, you know, tackle their day. They're not organizing themselves properly. They'll touch something, they'll look at something, but then move on to something else, forget that they have that. So it sits there even longer.
Okay.
They still are very, very.
And then to be honest, or to be fair, the entire team struggles with the user reply, but ITBD gets more of them, so they have a harder time of keeping up with them, which, you know, that drives these times that we're speaking about. So the longer these tickets are just sitting there with no action,
the higher that number gets. So it's a matter of them just, you know, putting together a workflow for themselves that allows them to touch everything periodically. They don't need to stay on top of any one thing 100%. They just need to be able to see it all and prioritize.
Yeah.
So if you see a user replied, well, the person just replied to you and you saw it, maybe just check it out real quick. They might be telling you that they don't have any need for assistance anymore. You can just go ahead and resolve that thing.
Right, right. You might get a closure right there for all you know. Yep, yeah. Oh, that makes a lot of sense. One thing, Pritam, I'll take this as an action item. I'd love to sit with you and an engineer and just see what their interface is, right?
One 100%, so little things like that.
What's the dashboard that they're living out of look like? I've not only built a bunch of these in the past, but operated off of a number of them in the past. Being able to see what they're operating from, maybe we can give them some guidance as to, oh, well, you've got this number here and you've got this list here or queue here.
Right, let's use that in this fashion. Maybe we can give them some...
You know.
Yep.
High level, is it?
It's all, I agree with that and it's very simple, Lee. We have Dave inbox. It can't get it.
Yeah.
And I hate speaking this way because I know that it's all individual ability, but Jesus Christ, it's really easy, guys. Like, seriously, like, it's in your face. You have numbers. It's just right there. User replied, it only means one thing.
Right.
Yeah.
And then the number after that, that's a quantity. I mean, you know, so it's not, we're not building rockets here. It's kind of, it's, and it hasn't always been this way, Lee, but we have right now anyways, a really good process in place, really good tools. Dave in Box.
It's really all day, and Dave will tell you when you need to leave Dave to go do something somewhere else. So you can really just like hang out there all day long, looking at your inbox. What do I have? What do I need to act on? Somebody just replied on one of my tickets. Let me get them a quick reply. If not, let me just tell them, thank you for that update.
Yeah.
Date or whatever, I'll be right back with you and move on.
Yeah, yeah, I mean, I remember these days well. So, you know, when I think back to how many tickets I've seen sit open, because somebody just didn't acknowledge a user saying, yeah, I'm good.
One 100%, so, like, and and...
You know.
Just to give you an idea, right, right now.
ITBD is or worker 14 is sitting on.
I know, Will. Don't get mad.
It's okay, you're amongst friends. Twenty-two.
22 user replied. Let me.
Looks like inbox froze.
Jim.
That changes, that updates the status of the ticket to user reply.
As soon as somebody replies to the ticket, yep, and so it's...
Which in every logical engineer's mind tells you there's required action on our side.
That's my thought, Lee, but...
I won't see any more. It's at twenty-six right now, so, and um, yeah, so twenty-six.
And we, you and me both, you and me.
Okay.
And.
And what I'm looking for now is to see what we have, and...
We have one that hasn't been updated since the 29th, which was yesterday.
Yesterday, OK.
That's the that's the oldest that hasn't been updated.
Correct.
All right, it's better than better than many have seen, not to say that, not to justify.
Yeah, and it's a reopen, so you know it looks like you know it was resolved engineer made like, but if we have the engineers and they're on top of it and they're looking in the inbox, whoever that ticket belongs to, that popped right back in, and they should have it because...
Okay.
But unassigned, so it would be it would be in the group.
For them to reply, so it's, you know, free-for-all.
Yeah.
No, actually, uh...
Yeah, there, there's a there's a they have a they have their inbox, which is the tickets personally assigned to them, but then they also have there's a general like work group view, which is everything for the entire work group, so at any given time they can see what you know, basically the numbers around all the tickets for for our team, so...
There is a user replied box that I encourage the entire team to work out of. I mean, yes, obviously, I always tell them, you know, look at your inbox, because I feel like that's probably easiest for an engineer to handle at any given time is you want to address the tickets that are signed to you personally. But then in conjunction with that, we do, Rodge and I, we pick, we have a schedule to have an engineer dedicated.
Yeah.
to help out specifically with more for chat communication, because it can be hard to juggle chats and calls. So we usually will just assign someone to handle just chats for periods of time. And that person in between chats, we also have them work on user reply tickets, where you can hop in there and just...
You know, to Jose's exact point, just read the ticket. What was the last thing that said? What's the next action here? Are we just acknowledging that they're saying, hey, I'm good, close it. Do we need to do something? Sometimes it's a simple thing, like I do it myself. Sometimes the person just wants to know, you know, like I just saw one earlier. We got a ticket, the person was.
Effectively applying for an IT job, they were just saying like, hey, you know, I'm looking for a career change. I want, so I'm reaching out, reaching out to service desk about that. Our response effectively is just, yeah, talk to your HR department. Like that's gonna be the response there, but that's all there is to it. So like that sort of stuff, it, it.
Yeah.
It can be done fairly quick and easily. It's just a matter of keeping an eye on it and trying to, I can understand how it can be difficult to juggle that when you have calls coming in as well. Email tickets, of course, are somewhere in the background of all of that too. So we have to make sure we're getting to email tickets. But yeah, that's what me and Roger here for as well.
To help help focus them on that, but the main areas I always try to drive their attention to, it's like if you're not on a currently on a call or a chat.
you know, that's the perfect time to check your queue. Did anybody respond to anything that you just worked? You know, and I feel like it's easier for them now than it used to be back, you know, in our old ticketing system. I used to have the page used to have to auto refresh, and it was not as nearly convenient to notice.
which ones were people had responded to recently. We didn't have the user replied status back then. So yeah, it was a lot more challenging in my opinion. So this is just a matter of, you know, trying to find those moments throughout your day as a natural workflow. Like I said, I used to look between every ticket, just.
Yeah.
Take it, because all it takes is a glance. Did anybody say anything? No? Okay, I'm moving on to my next thing for now.
Okay.
Yeah, absolutely. Agreed.
Oh.
Okay, Pritam back to you. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you, Lee. Thanks, Jose.
Sorry, yes.
I was talking about the IV team. I can see the difference as well. Also, I was talking to Rodge and Nico Jaime. So definitely I can see the admin time being going down now. So they are recording their time entries correctly.
Talking about Charles, he joined us and I have received his credentials, so most probably I will put his machine to the data price domain. So, William, it will be you who will be spending time with him, or how does, how are you planning?
It's going to be a combination of myself and we're also likely going to have to pull in the previous team lead for this work group that who was here before, the one who was doing this before Rodge. He's still with the team. He's just on our tier 2 team now. So if it'll probably be a lot of him training him, but if it's not him, then yes, it's going to be me. So we're going to.
Me and him are going to effectively tag team training for Charles.
Okay.
So once he's up and running, like set up with his systems and all, I will also make him spend some time with the team here so that he understands the type of tickets and all. And in the meantime, we'll ask you to schedule some time with him so that you can also start giving him the downloads.
Mmh.
Understood.
That's way too, we have to, he has to go through training first. He's going to be with Emily for like, okay.
Yes.
Yeah, yeah, I was gonna say that, that's always our step one is the training with Emily, just to get familiar with all the systems, yeah.
Correct. He will go through the training after that.
Yeah.
Right.
Now, good news, Jose, for you is we are good with OT, and I already have all the things done from the HR in the Philippines. So, William, how does our onboarding look like now?
Or caught up now because they use my team, so ha ha, but they, they, those come, those things come all the time, so that's good. It's good to know that we're good, we're set up properly for the future, so that's good. And they're good that they can also work on call then or no.
Mm.
Yes.
Ohh, my God!
Yeah.
Yep.
on call.
They can, but I think we need to establish the VPN. VPN.
It's the same thing, it's overtime, Pritam.
What about VPN?
I may need to establish the VPN for them for on call.
Because if they need to log into the enterprise system from their home IP, which I will not trust it, so I would ask them to use the VPN setup to log into the VTI.
Yeah.
They don't, do they have laptops? What type of setup do they have? Do you have for them?
They currently, it's connected to your data price domain, their laptops.
Oh, oh, we then they would have, then we would give them our VPN then, that's not a problem, yeah, OK. Um, they don't have VPN already, you will?
Yes.
So...
Wouldn't that be from day one?
I don't think so.
I don't think they have VPN. They directly log into the VDI.
Oh.
I don't, I never checked it with them because they were on site, but I can check. But to your point, because of how they access the network currently, it was never needed before. I think they have it though. It should just be on their machines, but I don't know if we ever tested it.
Thank you.
I...
I think so.
Okay, then it should be in their machines, but here, since they all work from office only, they come in and we have the IPs whitelisted at your end. So they just log into the VDAs.
Okay.
Mhm.
Okay, well then yeah, for we'll check, but tier ones do tier ones, tier twos, team leads, every like we have, you know, the on call and to make it fair, because it is extra money, one for those engineers, right? And 2.
Oh.
it increases the rotation in between. So the more engineers I have, the bigger gap between when they have to do it makes it fair for the rest of the team. Right? Like if I come up, if Jose is doing on call every two months, but you know, James is never doing on call, then Jose is not that happy. I don't care how much money you give me. I'm always on call and he's not.
Yep.
So we're trying to make, you know, to try to make it as fair or make it unfair for everyone. I don't care how you look at it, but you know, have everyone on par. So that's, I have everyone else. The only team that I need on that is yours.
Okay, okay.
OT, we are good because they're working from office. On call, I will just check. So when you say on call, Jose, how does it work? Weekly, weekends?
Yeah.
It depends on the role. So if they're tier one, it is weekly, seven days. And if it's tier 2, it's for...
Um...
Tier 2 is actually 7 is just a weekend.
S.
Yeah, it's just the weekend.
And team leads.
Same thing.
So really, tier ones are the only ones that do the whole week.
And it's once a month.
No, it depends. It could be every two months, every three months, because it depends on how many individuals I have in there. So like right now for the amount of people I have, I think it's like every month and a half or every two months that they're rotating in and out. The more bodies I have, the longer it'll be between they do that.
Okay.
Mhm.
But I, because I already have on call for one of my partners and it's kind of tricky because the bill rates are different.
I don't want a different building.
Because, no, so why builders are different because Philippines law, you know, it's a standard pay plus the number additional hours they work.
So weekly they get a standard on call pay, which is equivalent to their payouts. And in case they work, it's hourly basis. So I need to calculate that every month and send it to finance for billing.
Yeah.
And if it is on a rest day, it's a rest day OT. If it is on a holiday, it's a holiday premium pay or double pay. Yes, it's tricky in Philippines.
All right.
As per the labor laws, so I will just verify that and send you over for the on-call thing, how the rates will work. If you're okay with that, we are good. Not a major thing, it's just like OT only, overtime only, but it's just let's say if they work on a ticket on the on call after hours.
It may be 100 and twenty-five percent pay.
Okay.
hourly. If it's a rest day and they're working, it might be RDOT, rest day, OT means 200% their pay, something like that.
This is correct, okay.
All right.
It's tricky. It's work for me, not them, okay? They just work and you need to check their timeshare, then do this calculation. Yeah, I just do the calculation, then send it to finance for approval, then they send it to you.
And then they just get paid.
Okay, okay, yeah, just get us the rates and then we'll discuss it on our side and we'll make it, you know, the determination. But if I'm thinking that if on call is allowed, then everything should be good. I mean, not on call, overtime.
OT we are good. So OT we are good with it. Just that if you need these people to do OT, let me know or Charles in future, no, we can get that volunteered person to do the overtime and we can bill you in the next cycle. It's A straightforward calculation.
Uhh...
That works, OK.
Right, apart from it, William, I have sent you a couple of interviews tomorrow.
Mhm.
And I have also invited Abigail. You might have received it from a different email address. That's our bench email address. I forwarded it to you as well, Jose.
Okay, thank you.
Oops.
Now, it got.
I know, and he just dropped off.
He may have not had anything, he may have not had anything for you if he dropped off. Don't worry about it. He just comes around to like make sure he's aware of everything, but sometimes he's not gonna, he's not gonna interact.
Okay.
Mhm.
And.
Unless he has to.
And then the.
Yes, this two guys who you will talk to tomorrow, I'm sourcing more. This can be either in addition to Abigail Spot, that's work group.
Mhm.
Fourteen, I think.
For group 14, 12, 12, yeah, 14 is IV, or it can be a replacement for Carmina.
Abigail's 12, yeah.
No, yeah.
Yeah.
It's up to you.
She was also working with 12.
Yeah.
Yeah, work group talk. Okay, both Abigail, yeah, both Abigail.
Right, yeah, that's all I have.
Um...
Did we do?
****, did we terminate Carmina? I think we did. I don't remember if I put in her term. I know you told me to.
You?
I dropped you that email, yeah.
Any which way she is not logging in because...
Did I reply and say that I did it? Let me check.
She's not logging in because her laptop has changed. That I know.
Yeah.
No, I'm okay. I don't care about that. I just want to make sure that...
I haven't terminated her, I don't think.
When was her termination?
Ohh, ****.
You didn't do it well because it would have been work group 12. I wonder if Addy did it.
I think we were going to have Addy do it, but I think there was a question if her permissions in the system were set up to allow her to do it yet. I think that was the...
Yeah, I know that she told me she did one. I asked her to put it in the terminate, but, and then she told me that it didn't, and then...
Okay.
Lindsay came back and said that it wasn't put in for that person. So I wonder if she had a problem.
Kour.
Let me ask.
I...
I was gonna say, I'd do it for you, but I didn't have X.
I could have sworn she told me she did it. No, I think she told me she did it.
I did drop an email on 19th of June, but yeah, I have not received any response. Yeah, from Noel, not sure.
I remember when the email came.
From no one.
That means it didn't happen. Let me see.
*** **** it. Um, it doesn't, it's okay. She hasn't been clocking in. It's not like she's working in.
Yeah, yeah, she's not logging in.
She's not logging into the enterprise, I know.
You.
Well, like, did Will, look for her online real quick and see if she's still even here.
What?
Oh.
I can say I didn't see her on the dashboard when I checked it earlier today.
Ha ha ha!
No, she's gone. She's like her profile comes up as in like she's gone, like terminated. It's the white dot.
Yeah.
A known user, huh?
Mm.
OK, but most probably you guys might have done it, but forgot responding or something like that.
So, she was her.
I think it was done Pritam, but it just wasn't done by me because I can see all the ones I've submitted. I submitted one today. So...
No.
Abigail might have done it then.
Oh, yeah, I think...
I was gonna say, I know I didn't do it because I didn't have access. Carmina wasn't under me, so I couldn't do it.
I know for terminate employees.
I don't have her. I don't have her.
I have three other ones and she's not one of them, so it must have been Abby.
But she's definitely, it looks like she's termed in the system.
Yeah.
Alright, I'll verify with her, and if not, then I'll do it, but that's no big deal.
It's not gonna kill anyone.
Let's keep it here, between us though. No, just kidding.
Yep.
PH.
Yeah.
Okay, so those interviews are when?
Tomorrow, I, yeah, tomorrow. I have also forwarded you that invite separately, you and Lindsay, so that she is also where the interviews are happening.
Next week, tomorrow.
Okay, cool. Yeah, she's really the most important one because if we end up hiring someone and we communicate in that same message, then she can see that we're moving forward with whoever it is. If not, then we need to notify her that, you know, who we are moving forward with. So she knows.
But that's okay. All right, so you have two interviews for tomorrow, Pritam, then?
Yes.
Cool.
I don't see them.
At on.
I did send it. It's 10, 10 and 10.30 Eastern.
But I, I'm not.
So, let's say definitely on my calendar, I got it, so...
It's at 10 and 10.30.
Today?
Kumar.
Tomorrow, 1st of July.
No, no, but you sent them when?
Today, I'll send it today.
Yeah, I don't have anything from you today.
Yeah.
Hold on, hold on, let me take that back. Let me do a proper search.
I don't think I saw your name on.
Earl.
Ah, so I see one here for Charles, and he's back filling the Rodge.
No, you'll get it's not from my email address. It's from Tanya. Tanya.
Ohh.
I see Tanya. Oh, I did accept that. Okay. I was wondering who the hell Tanya was. Okay.
Yeah.
Ha ha ha!
I took the interview anyways, I was like, or the meeting. I'm like, all right, Tanya, we'll meet tomorrow.
Yep, yep.
Because I have no clue. Have we met Tanya?
But...
I think we did. It might have just been a while.
Yeah, initially, initially she, yeah, she actually takes care of the bench, you know, like scheduling the interviews and blah, blah, blah. So somehow I told them that I'm going to present this to them and I have the slots from William and she sent out the invite. I said, okay, no worries.
Ah, the first day, I thank you.
Then I forwarded the invest to you and Lindsay.
Kurt.
Uhh...
Alright, that's all I have.
Yeah, I think we are good and...
Thank you once again, Jose and William, for your time and the good comments. I'll definitely talk to the team. Once we are settled, I will check them out for a party sometime.
Yeah, no, get them, give them a good, you know, a pat on the back. They're doing fantastic. Let them, you know, and no matter what, you know, even with the new ones, Pritam, let's take that approach of just making them feel comfortable. Even with whatever feedback we gave, we give you, we're going to be honest with you.
Data promise.
Oh, okay.
I just need you to tune that to change whatever I say. Don't say what Jose says. Just make it, make it nice, you know, and make it, I just, for my comfort, I need to speak in clear language to make sure you understand me. But it's nothing, nobody's gonna die.
Mhm.
Yeah, I know.
Yeah.
Oh.
You know, we ******* fix computers here, Pritam. So like, it's not the end of the world. So yeah, they're doing fantastic. I see the improvement, which is all I can really ask for. And that's good. So whatever you're doing, whatever you guys are doing, whatever you did to help the team make them more comfortable, more confident.
Yeah.
That's true.
Yep.
Um, let's just keep doing more of that.
No, thank you. Thank you so much, Jose. And yes, thank you, William, once again. See you tomorrow during the interviews.
All right. All right. Take care, everybody.
Sounds good.
Thank you, bye.
Have a good morning there, Vikram.
You too. Good evening, sorry. Good evening.
Bye.